Nice pad richard you haven't changed at all bruce
you might be surprised
what was that back there a mess it's a way to
keep my lives separate i can't think of the
last time we saw each other i bet you can
remember the last time the first time too
i'm eager to learn they all say that ben turner
richard dragon shiva disciplined honorable
she's very dedicated
ben i assume you're in some kind of trouble
the Kobra cult a worldwide organization of
murderous zealots kill them we have to stop
it no matter what i ain't ever gonna turn
down whooping somebody's ass no matter how much
you train evil remains we're not done yet again
a quarry is a bit more formidable
than we thought that's handy
this isn't gonna be easy
remember you are stronger together than apart
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new Batman trailer video for the soul of
the dragon movie that's coming out in january next
year they basically made a batman blaxploitation
film like batman meets black dynamite but with
all dc characters so most of these characters
will seem familiar but there are some cool easter
eggs here because they have some actors that are
playing the animated versions of characters that
they already played in live action if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's going to be so many batman
movies coming out in the next couple of years both
animated and live action so i'll talk about some
of the other ones at the end of the video too
obviously we have ben affleck coming back as
batman and the justice league snyder cut and then
the flash flashpoint movie then we have the robert
pattinson batman movie with matt reeves but there
are a lot of animated batman movies coming up too
and the ones that they've been releasing including
this one are all rated r that's right the closest
you'll get to a rated r batman movie but the
synopsis for the movie just reads set in the
midst of the 1970s as you can tell because this
is blaxploitation this elseworlds adventure finds
bruce wayne training under a master sensei it's
here that bruce along with other elite students
is forged in the fire of martial arts discipline
the lifelong bonds that they form will be put to
the test when a deadly menace arises from their
past it will take the combined efforts of batman
world-renowned martial artist richard dragon
ben turner and lady shiva and their mentor oh
sensei to battle the monsters of this world and
beyond so they do get into some mystical stuff
during this like a lot of times batman villains
seem more practical like it's detective noir
thriller stories this is more of an action kung fu
story that spins up into more mystical territory
like if quentin tarantino did jackie brown as a
kung fu action movie with batman but they also
had a lot of spiritual mystical characters you may
recognize that michael jai white is playing bronze
tiger he also played the live-action version of
that character on arrow during their suicide squad
arc in season two only prisoners who grow coarse
and hardened from corporal punishment but those as
well who perpetrate the act or who are present to
witness it oh please stop giving him books so this
is your unit honeywell o.j and charles master
weren't available it was too bad they couldn't
bring him back for more episodes in later seasons
but i think that was more of an availability thing
and they also had the suicide squad movies like
the original suicide squad movie and the new one
that james gunn is doing so i think that precluded
them from doing more suicide squad stories kelly
who is playing lady shiva obviously she's shown up
in a bunch of animated projects like young justice
but the actress was also in a lot of those arrow
season 2 episodes as chyna white totally different
character but it's just cool to see so many arrow
characters and actors show up on this this is
their version of richard dragon though obviously
a version of him showed up in the final seasons
of arrow as one of the big bads that was more of a
new 52 version of the richard dragon character the
version that they're doing during this movie
is more of the original 1970s version of the
character he's being played by mark dicascos
from john wick he was amazing in that movie
most of you know richard dragon is a green arrow
comic book villain especially from the new 52
like i said but he actually debuted in his own
title back in the mid-1970s during the kung fu
pop culture craze both marvel and dc comics
were thirsty to get in on that action at the
time so they introduced their own versions of
real world pop culture heroes like bruce lee
and chuck norris as you can imagine like marvel
shang chi in the legend of the 10 rings movie
that's coming out next year it's marvel's version
of bruce lee's enter the dragon except it has an
actual dragon in it fing fang fume the shanxi
character was based on bruce lee in real life
richard dragon kind of came off as dc's
version of chuck norris in fun fact too
as this all gets really meta and starts crossing
over with each other chuck norris got his start
in the martial arts movies as a villain in a
bruce lee movie called the way of the dragon
their sensei also might sound familiar too
he's being played by james hong from big
trouble in little china one of my favorite deep
cuts in a billion other things like most of you
probably at least remember him from the kung fu
panda movies in this version of the story batman
richard dragon bronze tiger and lady shiva were
once fellow pupils under this sensei learning
kung fu in china before they all had their origin
stories and became superheroes or supervillains
years later after he's become batman they all
reunite when they learn about the threat from the
past which is basically the Kobra cult like they
say during the trailer that's another organization
that debuted during that kung fu craze of the
1970s and when i say that there's this mystical
aspect of the story they're basically a cult
they're called a Kobra cult trying to bring their
god into the world it's sort of this chaotic snake
god i don't know how much of those classic comics
they're doing but it just looks like a really fun
batman movie and like they said it's elseworld so
it's not meant to be in the same canon as the
movies like justice league apocalypse war or
the traditional justice league animated movies
usually you can tell which movies are canon to
that and which are not depending on who's voicing
the character but they kind of rebooted the dc
animated movies with justice league apocalypse
war and the latest flashpoint that they had the
flash pull at the end of that right now they're
just doing a whole bunch of elseworld stories
and like i said because batman is so big right
now they're reintroducing a brand new version
of the character in live action through robert
pattinson in the matt reeves batman trilogy and
movies it sounds like dc is just rolling really
hard on their batman franchise so it is a really
good time to be a batman fan but some of the other
upcoming batman movies that i talked about include
batman the long halloween they're doing that as
a two-part movie so obviously it's one of the
best batman stories of all time it's great that
they're doing a version of that comic book story
even the live action matt reeves batman movie is
adapting some elements of the long halloween even
though the story is original it just involves
a lot of plot elements and characters from the
long halloween story the animated batman long
halloween movie is actually going to be much
closer to the original comic book plot and they're
breaking it into two parts so that they can adapt
more of the story because usually their animated
movies are closer to 90 minutes and it's kind of
hard to fit an entire giant comic book arc into a
90 minute movie both parts of that part 1 and part
2 are coming out next year part one is supposed to
come out towards the end of the summer i believe
and then part two a couple months after that later
in the year originally they were going to overlap
with the live-action robert pattinson batman movie
but now that's been delayed to march 2022 so you
have to start saying the batman 2022 movie when
you're talking about the robber pattinson movie
i also just did a couple videos for the new batman
death in the family movie that they released on
home video it's basically a choose your own
adventure style version of under the red hood
done is a rated r movie i think under the red
hood was actually rated r back in the day as well
the difference with a new version is that you have
all these different character arcs and alternate
endings depending on which choices you make but
the thing is is you can only get these alternate
endings if you buy the blu-ray i think the
itunes release has some of the alternate endings
listed as bonus features but you don't get the
interactive aspect to it the visual novel mechanic
unless you actually buy the disc release if you're
a big anime fan or you've ever played any visual
novel games before it's the exact same thing
maximum weeb just make it batman and speaking
of shang chi that i mentioned earlier since marvel
has changed the order of the movies it's releasing
we might get a shang chi trailer sometime early
next year but i believe the black widow movie is
still going to be the first film marvel releases
we got all those avengers wandavision episodes
starting at the beginning of january next year
so we'll hear more marvel phase 4 stuff during
that and i'll cover that during my marvel videos
i try to keep the dc videos mostly about dc stuff
but everyone let me know in the comments what you
think of this and which other batman stories you
want them to adapt into movies even rated r batman
movies and let me know if you read any of those
classic batman kung fu crossover stories back
during the 1970s some of this is really deep cuts
i've got a new mandalorian season 2 episode
4 video that'll post this friday and a couple
other bonus videos but leave all your requests
in the comments below i just did a video for the
brand new justice league snyder cut trailer in
the commentary the zack snyder did on it you can
click here to watch that and you can click here
to learn all about that new mandalorian season 2
ahsoka tano scene thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!